Marjorie Taylor green the radical
republican congresswoman famously went
into New York City yesterday with a
protest the protest was going to be at
noon in support of trump then the it was
moved up to 10 30 a.m it was obviously
not going to go very well and I'm going
to show you a couple of clips of this
but Marjorie Taylor green ended up
having to flee her own protest as
hecklers completely shut the entire
thing down here is Marjorie Taylor green
with a megaphone trying to speak to the
crowd uh and yet there are so many
people with whistles that you can't hear
a damn word she's saying it's it's just
it's delightful and remember guys
This is speech this is everyone's speech
she is she has a megaphone and people
have whistles and it's speech versus
speech
[Applause]
already
by the way there appear to be more
members of the media there than actual
people protesting in support of trump
[Music]
who are doing their jobs
[Applause]
all right so you get it just nobody can
hear what she's saying and it's just all
pathetic now at another point
I I am told that the actor Michael
Rappaport who hates Trump
that this is him yelling at Marjorie
Taylor green okay and there is some some
language in this clip I believe that
this is indeed Michael Rappaport there
and just dressing down Marjorie Taylor
green listen to this
[Music]
morning
[Applause]
[Music]
hit him with the space laser and this is
as NYPD is like trying to clear a path
from Marjorie Taylor green and again
it's mostly reporters like it's it most
of the people there are reporters plus
Michael Rapaport screaming at her
[Music]
okay so a lot of screaming at this event
as Marjorie Taylor green had to be
rushed out by I guess security and NYPD
a democratic Congressman Jamal Bowman he
was not amused by Marjorie Taylor
Green's presence there do your freaking
job Marjorie Taylor green you don't need
to be in New York City talking that
nonsense go back to your District you're
not what are you doing here you're here
for politics you're here cause you want
to be VP you're here for your own
fundraising you're here for your own
nonsense yeah so Jamal Bowman accurately
pointing out what this is all about and
then lastly this is really weird when
Marjorie Taylor green was able to flee
to her car she did an interview with
Steve Bannon who refers to her as
as Congressman for so for some reason I
can't really figure out and she claims
that Eric Adams the mayor of New York
City organized a counter protest against
her check this out uh Congressman Greene
Congressman green
apropos of nothing Steve Bannon refers
to Marjorie Taylor green as Congressman
for from the gender realists very
surprising thing to hear uh Congressman
Greene the mayor of New York Eric Adams
specifically singled you out as a
hooligan that's going to cause a problem
and that you're dangerous and that
you've got to back off and go home your
thoughts ma'am
he didn't just single me out Steve he
threatened me he called me by name and
threatened me the mayor of New York City
I believe is is a thug and he sent his
people here today they had an organized
text uh alert that went out calling what
I would say antifa to bring their
whistles pots and pans all kinds of
instruments to make they brought pots
and pans and they almost started making
a souffle all kinds of noise to drown me
out and drown others here today that are
protesting and here supporting president
Trump the mayor of New York City mayor
Adams owes me an apology I'm an elected
member of Congress I represent hundreds
of thousands of people from Northwest
Georgia but I also represent Americans
all over the country uh that support
anyway you know the really funny thing
was the guy handing out the whistles was
actually reported to be a trump
supporter so like the idea that it was
the left that organized the whistle
protest I I guess a trump supporter
thought that by handing out whistles
they would be able to drown out the
anti-trump protesters across the street
but all it actually did was drown out
Marjorie Taylor green and I'm sure some
anti-trump people gladly accepted
whistles as well so complete and total
chaos on the streets of New York City
and I agree with Jamal Bowman why is
Marjorie Taylor green even there she has
nothing to do with New York City she
says New York City is a terrible place
she says that you know we've got all
this crime in New York City and so on
and so why why bother Marjorie just stay
home or go somewhere else or go to
Mar-A-Lago where she did ultimately end
up later yesterday evening so that was
the pr the big protest organized by
Marjorie Taylor green we'll take a quick
break and be back with so much more